are you excited it's Friday I am because
that means it's time for Friday Follies
and for that we turn to Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo
all right Ray Biden
seemed to be malfunctioning today
Laura it was billed as a big speech on
AI where the president had assembled
corporate leaders to reign in AI but by
the looks of things he could have used
some artificial intelligence realizing
the promise of AI by managing the risk
is going to require some new laws as we
advance the agenda here at home we'll
lead to work with will lead work with
our allies and partners I think these
leaders and I thank these leaders are in
the room with me today and their
partnership
excuse me can you tell us about the
hacking of cabinet officials by China
and the threshold of concern you have
about that sir ready yes
[Music]
China hacking something
the poor man we've seen the president in
nearly every public event unsure of how
or where to exit but apparently he
doesn't know where he's going at home
either how do you get lost at the White
House I mean he's going to reign in AI
he can't Reign himself into the right
direction to leave the room you know
those kids who are at daycare and they
have that little string the Rope the
thing they hold on to and they need to
just have that for Biden that little
whatever that little Bridal or whatever
it is all right Ray I see that you're
rubbing you're rubbing your lamp there I
am so I guess I'm granting you three
wishes I'm so generous what's first
oh benevolent Genie I wish politicians
particularly former presidential
candidates would stop talking about or
start talking about things that matter
and leave the unessentials aside
especially when you're on the clock at
the Capitol I give you Oscar Meyer
Romney
well as you all know today is National
Hot Dog Day and perhaps you also know
that hot dog is my favorite meat I love
hot dogs I love them in buns I love them
outside of buns that's the best you know
best meat there is well Laura I guess if
anybody knows a wiener it's Mitt Romney
the last time he encountered a hot dog
though it was in a cage on the roof of
his car as I recall so you know you
should leave the hot dog comments yeah
it never worked in 2012 when he tried to
be kind of casual he's just like a
button-down guy that's okay but it just
doesn't
doesn't work no it's your second wish
well my second wish is also food related
I wish when the Biden staff staged say
an ice cream giveaway with union workers
that someone would help the president
pass them out like an adult rather than
a three-year-old
understand
[Music]
Laura he tosses the ice cream at him
like he's at the seal house and did you
see the way he ripped the igloo top off
you you would have sworn there was a
barisma payment in that thing he just
ripped it right off knocked it over well
I'm sounding like um our friends over at
MSNBC but couldn't they have had that
cooler elevated for the poor man I mean
he looks like he's I mean it could fall
over at any moment I mean that's just
another Hazard for him they've got to be
very careful Third Wish Last Wish Laura
I wish decrepit elderly Paul's would
stop trying to convince us that they're
hip and with it here's a Biden ad
claiming the president will read your
texts Laura to him texting is getting
the middle letter straight on the
printing press what are they talking
about he's going to read your text then
he needed the assistance of that
whippersnapper Bernie Sanders to meet
with young union workers note Biden's
level of concentration in this edited
White House video
the president did what I don't know has
ever been done before invite young
workers right here into the White House
We Know what needs to be done
refused
and bargaining
won't recognize us as uh represented by
a union free unionization a lot of guys
were hesitant myself included
Laura those poor kids left thinking
we'll never be unionized at this point
yeah the purple hair number hunting
Biden's like what is this looking at
going what all right
um now do I get a wishing you a wish I'm
granting your wish now okay all right
let me think about his fair play
I wish politicians would stop trying to
attach themselves to these pop culture
moments like Governor Gretchen whitless
Whitmer she's my favorite and her staff
they've been posting pictures of her and
her personal Barbie called little Gretch
okay yeah and they're now what are they
doing with it
yeah they're they're sending to her on
her own Adventures little Gretch and
posting them on social media Michigan
Governor Gretchen Whitmer became Barbie
little wretch rolling out in style in
her pink convertible hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
I don't know oh my God I I can
understand the comparison Laura because
Barbie has almost as much plastic as big
Grinch I understand why they would want
when you first said it was like I
thought it was big the big wretch that
would have made a lot more sense not the
big Grinch I don't do they understand
there's a there's a confidence issue
there Raymond happy Friday and thank you
for my wish hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else